[Musique]
ici à Guédelon au cœur de la fusée non
loin du centre Val de Loire nous avons
fait un voyage dans le temps en plein
cœur du Moyen-Âge Marilyn Martin est à
l'origine de ce projet fou qui est la
construction d'un édifice médiéval avec
les techniques et matériaux de l'époque
oui de l'époque et vous allez voir
qu'ils ont vite appris que c'est en
forgeant qu'on devient forgeron et moi
aussi je suis en train d'apprendre les
techniques du Moyen-Âge
c'est chaud
Marilyn doute est venu cette idée folle
de créer Guédelon l'idée elle est pas
d'hier elle est de 25 ans et c'est parti
tu vois du château de Saint-Fargeau qui
a 15 km d'ici ou en fait le propriétaire
après une étude qu'on lui a rendu sur
son château c'est dit bah tiens sous mon
château de Brie qui a un château de
pierre du 13e siècle et on s'est dit si
on construisait Saint-Fargeau englouti
et un élément qui compte aussi dans
toute cette histoire c'est le groupe ici
on fait rien tout seul je vais te faire
visiter le chantier
[Musique]
alors voilà Camille tu vois là c'est le
chantier qui est en activité en ce
moment on va monter les deux tours qui
sont là c'est là dessus qu'on accrochera
tout le système pour la Hertz pour
qu'elle se lève et qu'elles aient
descendent pourquoi vous avez choisi cet
endroit pour faire guiderons et pourquoi
pas ailleurs ce lieu bien particulier
c'était notre réserve de pierre et notre
réserve en matériaux il fallait trouver
il y aurait nous cette carrière on l'a
acheté des poignées
une mais elle allait nous permettre de
tout trouver sur place pour construire
des artisans à travailler ici on est 70
55 personnes qui travaillent à la
construction du château à l'aide d'un
oiseau
100% du budget de Guédelon et financé
par nos visiteurs la boutique les restos
tu peux pas avoir un projet fou et
demander aux autres de te le financer
tout le monde est capable de faire
quelque chose à gagner de loin moi je
pourrais chanter par exemple là
[Musique]
je te laisse avec les forgerons sans
forgeron un gué de long pas de chantier
la forge la forge la forge Philippe
comment ça va
ça va bien qu'est-ce que tu es en train
de faire là couteau de cuisine couteau
de cuisine il est grand ma mère serait
ravie avec ça tu peux faire du point
d'eau tu peux faire le mafé alors
qu'est-ce que tu peux me montrer on peut
taper là moi j'ai envie de taper j'ai
envie d'apprendre c'est pris là je peux
faire un peu les alors peut-être un clou
c'est parti un petit clou un petit clou
toujours des petits clous un petit clou
un petit clou encore des petits clous tu
commences par quoi alors on va commencer
par monter la barre à 1000 degrés on
voit du rouge à 800 degrés orange 950
jaune 1100 et blanc 1250 alors il y a
Marilyn qui m'a dit le forgeron c'est
l'élément indispensable pour un tel
projet nous notre grosse partie du
travail à Guédelon c'est de réparer
entre 10 à 30 outils de taille de pierre
tous les jours parce que la pierre est
dure elle suce vite donc c'est vrai que
c'est au bout d'une semaine on arrête de
travailler il y a plus d'outils peuvent
plus extraire la pierre ni la tailler en
fait c'est parti je vais écraser la tête
et voilà
un clou de Guédelon voilà bah je te
laisse continuer de travailler hein je
fais ton travail embêter toute la
journée
[Musique]